the holocron is a giant encyclopedia
basically of all the characters and
planets and ships and events from the
Star Wars Expanded Universe from the
movies from the TV show anything that
has to do with the Star Wars universe
and goes into this database and so part
of my job is filling the database so
whenever we create new characters or we
create new world new aliens it goes into
this database and then another aspect of
my job is to as we're creating new
content we're making sure that that new
content fits within the existing
continuity so we're checking to make
sure that names are spelled right that
we don't kill a character more than once
that they have a consistent lightsaber
color that if a character gets married
when did they get married if they have
kids with the planet they're from things
like that we try to make everything fit
together whether it's from the movies
from the TV show from the games the
books the toys we try to keep it all one
universe having a single continuity the
ramifications of what happens in a
certain story have more impact they're
more lasting so if the character dies
that character is dead you're not gonna
see them come back in another story so
we killed Chewbacca in one of our novels
well Chewbacca is not going to appear
later in the timeline in a game or comic
we're not gonna bring Mace Windu's back
I mean we find ways to sort of we kind
of did bring the end for her back when
we kind of did bring the bring Boba Fett
back but there's an explanation whenever
when it wasn't they like a half that
happens we retcon something when we need
to fix something that didn't fit in the
past an example would be
bobafet previous vocals before war
episode 2 said that boa Fett was bees
who may have been a performer's
stormtrooper that he was just what they
call a journeyman protector from this
planet called Concord dawn and then
episode 2 comes along and Oh actually
Boba Fett's is cloned from Kamino
and he's cloned after this guy named
Jango Fett rather than completely
trashing that the whole backstory that
we've had for Boba Fett before we took
that we retconned it and we applied that
backstory to Boba Fett's or to Jango
Fett Boba Fett's dad we were supposed to
know the motivations of the characters
better than anyone else is that
character acting like like they do like
a fan would expect them to when it's
coming to a to us for approval we have
the ability to make changes to them
material and if it doesn't fit within
within certain standards and and if if
things veer off from from what is
expected for a character yeah we'll
definitely have them change it
you